hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts precision medicine and
juvenile psychosis presented by
Catherine Bronson PhD and instructor in
pediatrics at Boston Children's Hospital
I am Kristen Perez and peel of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar I presented by
lab group laberd's it's deleting
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left at the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and most offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Katherine Bronstein I will now turn the
presentation over to her
thanks so much and today I am so happy
to speak with you about precision
medicine in juvenile psychosis I'm going
to be giving some case examples from
individuals at Boston Children's
Hospital and give a bit of a background
as to the infrastructure that we've been
utilizing to enable precision medicine
and help all these individuals so just
some background first Boston Children's
Hospital is a 395 Budd quaternary care
magnet Hospital
we do pretty much everything except for
burns we refer patients to a burn center
for that we have over 65,000 unique
emergency department visits over 25,000
admissions and over half a million
clinic visits per year and we have a
long history of doing research were
awarded the most NIH pediatric research
dollars in the US and we've been Cerner
computerized prescriber order entry
since 2005 and we are the first
pediatric institution to receive him
seven designation which means that we're
all computer electronic no paper for our
orders so patients and Families come to
Boston Children's Hospital with two
fundamental questions what's wrong with
my child or me and what's next for us
and for many patients genetic testing
and clinical expertise especially that
in Boston Children's is used to answer
these questions but it requires a lot of
hard work and sometimes some serendipity
in order to answer these things so you
have to have an accurate phenotype you
have to have the ability it's much
easier to do genetic testing if the
parental or complete trio is available
or even extended pedigrees we have to be
able to have adequate interpretation so
we can actually figure out what's wrong
and then if you have an idea of what's
going on but you're not a hundred
percent sure you need to be able to move
the case over to research and have a
scientific community with the ability
and the willingness to investigate and
to provide functional validation for
genes and variants of interest when
warranted and this investigational
investigation is very time-consuming and
often expensive and finally if you are
able to make a diagnosis then you need
to have the patient specific care
management plan which means that
everything has to be tailored to the
individual which is the crux of
precision medicine but also as one of
the most challenging aspects
and just an example of how this works
for family 165 and the mountain centre
for orphan disease research we couldn't
figure out what was going wrong with
this child who had intellectual
disability with extreme hairiness as a
child and with no known cause one of the
investigators here I thought it might
look similar to Zimmerman levan syndrome
and happened to know that there was
someone at Baylor College of Medicine
who specialized in Zimmerman Levin so we
emailed the investigator and that
specialist to see if this indeed look
like a case investigator wrote back no I
don't think so
but had the photos up on his computer
and a colleague walked by and said oh
that looks like him to syndrome and so
this investigator emailed us have you
checked kid to Cantu is ABC c9 and the
individual the child did not have a
mutation in that disorder but we notice
that the child did have a de novo which
means a variant that wasn't seen in
either parents when Casey nj8 and Casey
nj8
was known to pair with ABC c9 so we
considered it to be a pretty exciting
candidate it was predicted by pathogenic
as being pathogenic and both sift and
polyphen to which if you aren't familiar
the most probably the most widely used
protein prediction algorithms and the
gene had been previously associated with
through gada syndrome so it was pretty
easy to find a clinic that we do
clinical testing so we are able to get
this CLIA confirmed quite easily um and
I guess again it formed a potassium
channel of ABC c9 which was the known
gene for count two syndrome so all
together it seemed like a pretty eggs
sweat much of a slam-dunk
but think about this again it was only
diagnosed because we emailed an expert
that we thought was an expert in the
hypothesized condition and then someone
happened to be walking by who actually
was familiar with the actual diagnosis
there's way too much serendipity that's
involved in these types of cases so our
mission here is to take out some of
these this camps that has to occur in
order to make a diagnosis and make it
more of the standard how do we empower
patients to better understand them their
symptoms and connect them to the right
resources at a timely fashion how do we
improve the annotation process how does
software help map phenotype to potential
diagnosis and how do we continue to
understand the implications of a
diagnosis on prognosis and care plan and
then who do we partner with in order to
accelerate the department development of
narrow novel therapeutics and basically
the answer is to collaborate whenever it
necessary so I am scientific director as
a mountain centre for orphan disease
research and this is a philanthropic we
funded virtual Center that was
established in 2008 which focuses on
under studied and under diagnosed
conditions and creates models for
understanding them better we have a
senior scientist program ingeras endowed
scholarship junior faculty career
development awards pilot project awards
but most excitingly as a gene discovery
core protocol this protocol came about
because Tim's Pankaj Agarwal who's my
colleague was noticing that infants were
presenting in the NICU a seemingly
genetic disorders but there was no means
for research follow-up in both
clinically in diagnosed and undiagnosed
cases either you have to try and find a
protocol that already existed and cram
your patient in there whether they fit
perfectly or not or you had to create an
IRB protocol in order to enroll the
patient
to explain consuming and very difficult
so they wanted to find make a hospital
approved IRB protocol that had broad
inclusion criteria could allow for the
partnership of clinicians and
researchers allow for the various
molecular and functional testing got
tailored to the case and but allowed the
samples to remain identifiable then it
had to have the infrastructure to return
results to families into the medical
record and the staff to prefer supports
the project development to oversee the
enrollment process and to maintain the
protocol and this basically was because
the clinicians did not simply did not
have time to write protocols to provide
the amendments to update them to have
the resources to consent the families to
research to be able to reach out to the
extended pedigrees when that was needed
it was just simply impossible and by
pooling efforts now everyone can benefit
from this wonderful protocol so the
limitations as we said before the
majority of cases need functional or
research follow-up even when they are
considered diagnosed now that's not true
at every single institution but it is
true here at Boston Children's and again
we are a tertiary or quaternary Center
so we are seeing some very difficult
cases but even when something is
considered diagnosed sometimes it's a
new mutation a new phenotype or new
questions are raised so here we're able
to have an interesting study population
of orphan diseases and we're able to
build cohorts when needed and on a
global basis we can reach out and find
other patients and even being able to
enroll people with more common diagnosis
but presenting in an unusual way and
then researchers and clinicians can use
the protocol to enroll participants that
they could work on directly and use our
infrastructure and then they have
identifiable access
two samples and we may request access D
identifiable samples already within the
database and we're able to bank saliva
or blood DNA I'm clinically obtained
tissues and we're able to do skin
biopsies which is great now so we can
make IPS C and we're able to do whole
exome and whole genome sequencing
protein expression and again we're now
working more and more with stem cells
since enrollment began in 2010 over
4,000 participants are enrolled I think
this is actually old slide and that
we're doing much more but what's
interestingly less than 7% of families
approach have done declined
participation and this is an important
point families want answers they want to
participate in research but even if they
know that it might not directly benefit
them which is tragically the case a lot
of the time they want to help and make
the move research forward and help the
next person who comes along who might
have the same condition we are global
organization enrollment can be done over
the phone and through the mail and
there's no cost to on patients so one
cohort that's use this a lot is what I'm
going to speak mostly about today which
is juvenile psychosis and we work on
juvenile psychosis because these are
edge cases normally there is a psychosis
occurs after puberty sometimes there
might be hints that something isn't
right before puberty but then there's a
deterioration and private psychotic
symptoms usually after puberty called
the prodromal period and then whether
the first episode in early psychosis
there's a less and less complete
recovery and then the chronic effects of
psychosis are that it leaves a chronic
disability with but sometimes with fewer
psychotic
observations so really catching these
cases early and intervening you're
trying to prevent the dramatic decline
of the first episode or prevent
subsequent episodes is paramount here
and what we are the overall goal of one
of the overall goals of the program so
schizophrenia is a neurodevelopmental
disorder clinically sometimes you see
manifestations in empathy in early
childhood which may include mild
cognitive and social delays and
developmentally inappropriate and
anxiety not responding to normal
exposures but sometimes you don't see
these in typical in cases so the
generation starts before the onset of
high-risk symptoms in the brain and the
Seabrook cerebral cortex is sometimes
thin and since further in patients that
becomes fully psychotic basically what
we are trying to say is that they are
physical ramifications from
non-intervention and that we are trying
to to prevent decline on several fronts
so in the developmental neuropsychiatry
program you're trying to identify
children who are at risk or in the
prodromal period or even before then we
are trying to do biological and
behavioral phenotyping to characterize
biomarkers and figura completely
longitudinally the phenotype we do
genotyping exome plus chromosomal micro
away array but now as the price of
genome has reduced we're doing more and
more genomes identifying faulty genes
and pathways then we're studying neuron
function in IPS ES and in animal models
and identifying therapeutic targets
we're screening compounds to identify
targeted treatments incorporating
biomarkers into our diagnosis protocols
and then reevaluating long term course
and treatment of these children to see
how and how
they are doing and then taking these
things that we learn and applying them
back to back into the clinic to complete
this cycle and keep the research going
again we do clinical our whole exome or
genome sequencing plus a chromosomal
maker away
excellent plus microarray was a very as
getting the most bang for your buck just
because genomes were so much more
expensive especially when we first
started out and much more costly to
store but now as the price of genomes
have come down a lot especially research
genomes we just got a quote for I think
$1,600 including analysis we might be
moving to doing more of those and but we
study these youngest children because
these severe early onset cases are
helping us define highly penetrant teens
now schizophrenia is considered to be a
multifactorial sectoral disorder you'll
read a lot of studies out there that say
okay this variant increases your risk of
schizophrenia by one percent now these
are different types of cases these are
children who were psychotic from a very
young age three and four years old five
years old and these are much more likely
to be monogenic causes extremes are rare
causes with genes of large effect that
you don't typically see in the general
population so the first case is a nine
year old boy with a history of selective
mutism and severe aggression he
presented with hallucinations and
behavioral problems worsening dsm-5
criteria for childhood onset
schizophrenia at six years of age at two
months of age he was diagnosed with
decreased muscle tone for which he
started receiving clinton early
intervention services including physical
therapy sat at ten months which is late
took his first steps at thirteen months
and began babbling and speaking first
words at five and nine
respectively at two years of age he
exhibited severe head banging so he's
now nine years old mother was given
certainly and at the end of pregnancy
baby was born full-term with no
complications and we did he did have an
elevated blood lead level that
normalized after his family moved
intermittent exotropia which means one
eye move independently as other once in
a while and history of problems of motor
coordination don't and at nine was found
to have below average nonverbal and
spatial reasoning and though verbal
reasoning at age six he started having
hallucinations with with voices coming
out of the walls two voices telling him
to hurt himself and others has trouble
focusing on people talking to them when
the voices are talking and continues to
have visual hallucinations when the eyes
are closed in terms of seeing ghosts
aliens fingerprints on the wall and
footprints in colors and he's
importantly he did respond to an
antipsychotic he has a coffee number
loss of 16-piece or 2.11 means he is
missing one copy of a chromosome at that
location and this is including genes P
DX D C 1 and 10 1 & r RM 3 the mother
does not have this deletion and the
father was not available for Texas
testing he is not in the picture and is
that the inheritance is presumed to be
paternal or de novo which means with
father doesn't have it when it just
happen to have occurred in this is a
child a second case this child has a chi
re one malformation autism spectrum
disorder seizures and childhood onset
psychosis this is a five year old girl
born with c-sections with due to
concerns about maternal hypertension
began staring spells at 18 months and
generalized tonic-clonic seizure at 35
months now I was taking lamotrigine to
control seizures has in turn also has
intermittent exotropia and a history of
cyclic neutropenia and hypoglycemia and
delayed developmental milestones so
walking in nine months is not delayed
but the first weird at 2.5 years is
delayed and first phrases at 36 months
the diagnosis of mild autism was ugly at
that time intubation services started at
18 months now has good joint attention
and average fine motor performance
probably was sitting at nine months
Milwaukee case number two more on this
case far as the visual hallucinations at
four years of age including monsters a
big black wolf a man with blood on his
face crackers eating her hand and
spiders in her ears constantly was
telling people to get the spiders out of
her ears paranoid behavior would not
sleeping in a room saying it is waiting
for me and would speak continuously
about people staring at her again the
symptoms decreased in frequency and
intensity with an anti-psychotic and
further symptom mitigation hello far at
all
the family history has seizures in it on
both sides father had photo induced
epilepsy and the maternal grandmother
had petit mal like seizures I know
that's an out-of-date term um this child
has a copy number gained at 16 P
thirteen point one one now remember the
last case was actually copper number
loss at 16 P thirteen point one one this
area but this copy number game is
actually much larger than the loss so
that child was only moving copies of pdx
DC one R and three and I think Andy
or intend one on but this child is also
gaining copies of those three genes Plus
Nomo one and then tip and the e 1 ki a a
oh four three zero in addition to others
including two ABC C genes I don't know
if you remember but the first example we
gave was actually a b c c9 which was the
known gene for - a - syndrome so this
child also has a copy gain at xq 28 this
mutation or as a 60 and p mutation was
inherited from the father the father has
again epilepsy but not autism psychosis
or intellectual disability father also
has some other chromosomal games found
losses that perhaps are balancing the
copy number gain or in chromosome 16 but
that's just pure speculation
and again this region you can tell you
can have a copy number gain and a copy
number loss both ending up with juvenile
psychosis this radiation is an
associated with several disorders
including developmental delay
microcephaly epilepsy short stature
facial dismorphism behavioral problems
and schizophrenia
so there's refold excessive deletions
and duplications and schizophrenia cases
versus controls for this interval and
n10 one and mv1 are named as known
schizophrenia candidate genes so when we
see this but this is one of the first
times linked to juvenile onset
schizophrenia and with both a copy
number gain and loss which was quite
interesting and we are able to to
publish this just finding but since
there was a game in a loss and again two
completely different chromosomal
aberrations resulting in the same
phenotype we decided to look throughout
Children's Hospital and see were there
others with copy number variations at 16
P 13.1 one that are going undiagnosed
since this genomic region was associated
with so much perhaps they were being
treated for epilepsy without having any
behavioral problems being addressed
since they were not as crucial or
pressing as the epilepsy and we were
able to go back and identify patients
that did have copy number gains and
losses in this region and they we were
able to identify two patients that
needed behavioral problems addressed
where they work is previously going
undiagnosed or having to deal with the
problems on their own because there were
when they had to go to the hospital it
was because of seizures not because of
behavioral problems and they we can
consider these success stories a case
number three is also very interesting so
a child this is a cutout hood onset
psychosis case at the age of three he
was diagnosed with selective mutism
pervasive developmental disorder and
depression he was having described as
having severe mood swings lack of
emotional control and severe severe as
separation anxiety and severe and
self-interest behaviors for example II
tried to pull out his own teeth and to
cut out as gingiva with scissors at age
six years and two months he reported
auditory hallucinations and the sources
said bad things told him to hurt himself
and others and he felt like he needed to
obey them he thought that the voices the
boys of his head were real so here we
did both whole exome sequencing and it
did a chromosomal microwave and we found
that de novo missense change and a P P
183 this variant had not been described
but other app1 h3 variants have been
associated with which Parkinson's
parking is a severe our rapid onset
parkinsonism and then also to
alternating hemiplegia in childhood
it forms alpha sub ment subunit of a
sodium potassium ATPase complex and
again these the gene has been implicated
an array of psychological psychomotor
and neuromuscular abnormalities and
we've identified additional cases of
juveniles onto psychosis with de Novo's
in this gene and we are currently
forming a cohort to do on different
follow-up analyses working with stem
cells were actually having exciting
collaboration with the George Church
laboratory using organoids to look at
different types of neurons and to do
phenotypic and electrophysiological
studies and to hopefully start looking
at small molecule screens for the scene
in the near future
going back to 16 p 13.1 one we've
actually started working with the
Facebook group for children with
variation chromosomal variations in this
gene which is very exciting one thing to
note is that the chromosomal microarrays
don't have very many markers in this
area so we are looking into developing a
custom array so we can map the endpoints
of these gains and losses much better
which is important considering that
there's such a dramatic range in
phenotypes with this reagent that
mapping the endpoints and if there are
micro deletions or micro duplications is
paramount to truly understanding this
region so all these cases that we're
seeing at Boston Children's are
consented to the mountain centre which
means that when we have candidate
variants that seem to be clinically
actionable we can return the results
back to the medical record after getting
them CLIA confirmed and that the
invested the researchers I mean the
clinicians can take them into account
which is very exciting and allows us to
work quite closely with clinicians and
provide the best possible care for our
patients but where I mean there's always
room for improvement we need to figure
out ways to make this offer on pipeline
smoother we need to be able to narrow
down diagnostic options and we have to
be able to connect to outside of Boston
Children's Hospital more easily and more
exactly to find the specialist that they
need at in the timely fashion so one
thing that we've done is with the
Harvard Medical School is to have
contests to accelerate progress now this
isn't a new concept like the XPrize is a
quite known competition with the slogan
making the impossible possible and most
famously the protein scientists released
a bunch of protein folding problems to
the gaming community who are able to
make huge strides that were in problems
that traditional protein scientists
weren't able to do so in other words
contest work and they work quite well so
we have Milt Center who sponsor what's
along with Harvard Medical the clarity
challenges and for the first one we took
three families with mutations that were
thought to be Mendelian and/or in
inheritance and released them
internationally the data and the
phenotypes and 23 teams competed to find
out - how they could diagnose these
families and in the first competition
two out of three families were diagnosed
and the third actually had some very
exciting candidates that are now being
followed up on for the second clarity
challenge these the families were
already part of a fascinating
documentary called undiagnosed medical
refugees
and I put the website here so we weren't
choosing them because we thought they
were going to be ideal for the challenge
they were already part of the film and
this is an important point because you
know that's the way real life is and we
don't always get to choose the best
situation to release data
internationally so as a result we didn't
have any that were considered slam dunks
but again for the five families that had
their data released there were
interesting candidates for each one and
research is ongoing to follow up on
these leads so here the moral is is when
we don't know we we don't hold things to
ourselves being greedy helps absolutely
no one when we don't know we go to other
institutions sometimes other countries
to find the specialist that will be able
to provide the research and the
attention to the case that is required
and we're doing some very novel
partnerships so we're a part a finalist
in the Stanford medicine X program
that's also a partnership with Withings
and we applied on juvenile psychosis
wondering if these patients were
sleeping well now it's a challenge for
these families to get their children to
appointments in general more or less to
have them do an overnight sleep study
but there is a body of literature
showing that in schizophrenia sleep is
disrupted and that actually can
contribute to the phenotype of
schizophrenia so we wonder if that's
going on in juvenile onset psychosis I
don't know the stages of the people in
the audience but I know that for my
children if they do not have a good
night's sleep I can tell that they are
bears in excess
so we are wondering if that is actually
going on with children with juvenile
onset psychosis and if that there is a
measurable difference in the quality of
the day when they sleep well versus not
well and if the sleep is disrupted in
general so for 50 of our patients we are
getting the sweet aura from living where
at the pad placed under the mattress
that will record the movement and allow
us to get rough estimates of deep sleep
and how much they are tossing and
turning through the night and sweet
overall sleep quality so working
together with the innovation and digital
health accelerator here at Boston
Children's we are going to figure out if
for these children some subset or all of
them need to be referred to the sleep
clinic here at Boston Children's and if
they are going there is something some
intervention that we can do to improve
their sleep so increase in conclusion
Boston Children's has and is developing
infrastructure so to move from the
clinic back to research and then back to
clinic and this streamline process
allows us to make wonderful strides in
research and provide the best possible
care to our patients where juvenile
onset psychosis is a very sensitive
situation these children are are have a
lot of sub problems that hopefully are
can be addressed so they can go on to
become happy and productive adults and
so working with research and catching
these cases early and addressing the
problem is extremely important along
with the basic tenets of precision
medicine that we are giving them the
drugs that are most likely to work for
their particular situation not just
generalize disease treatment
recommendations but those that are
tailored to the individual research and
care is
or when you share data and collaborate
you know we can't stress this enough
like a lot of places unfortunately it
seems that people would rather fail on
their own than share credit then I'm
very pleased and happy to say that we
work at an institution where people
aren't afraid to share and they aren't
afraid to share credit because credit
and authorship is always infinite you
can always add another author you can
always share credit and put someone on
your work and nothing bad will happen
it's an important lesson and we are
lucky here that people seem to have
internalized that contest work that
thinking outside the box so sometimes
absolutely necessary especially in these
difficult cases and innovation is an
important part of precision medicine
where we need to not accept the status
quo we need to be thinking forward we
need to be thinking creative creatively
how do we get the data that we need to
make decisions how you know if the
person can't travel you know Boston
Children's recently started piloting a
program where they send robots home with
patients to do be able to get
measurements at home quite easily for
patients that are having a hard time
moving around and that's just one of
many examples where you know trying to
to not accept things for being difficult
and partnering with institutions that
weren't necessarily traditionally
involved in research is sometimes really
exciting and the possibilities are
endless
I guess I'm finishing early but will
leave more time for questions and I hope
that you enjoyed this presentation and
that I can answer any questions that you
may have thank you
thank you so much dr. Brownstein for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is how do
you know the children are actually
psycho
psychotic so this is actually the
question I get asked most frequently I
try to give some description of the
self-harm and the phenotypes extreme
phenotypes to give some idea but it is
true that sometimes children are just
going through a difficult phase and how
do you distinguish that from two
psychosis again because we're such a
tertiary quaternary hospital they've
gone through several rounds of testing
and several types of intervention before
they actually get to us so we're kind of
the last resort that gives us some more
confidence that the children truly are
having psychotic episodes rather than
something else I can easily be addressed
and then also just the extreme nature
where they are suicidal and when if you
saw them you would know that the
phenotype and what they're experiencing
is real and really looks like psychosis
not some other condition that could be
just making them behave that way in a
transient fashion okay thank you the
next question we have how do you consent
a psychotic parent or child of a
psychotic child it is a fairly desperate
situation I'm guessing Oh for consent
that's also one reason why I think the
Manton protocol is so valuable that we
have genetic counselors with many years
of experience
in difficult situations so we're not
having clinicians or doctors who could
possibly be persuading parents without
even knowing that I'm to enroll that we
have people who sit down is quite
intensive process to explain the risk
and benefit sorry and also we're are
able to work as a sanity check that they
can say you know what it's just doesn't
seem to be the right decision here and
put the brakes on it necessary okay
basically the short answer is that we
have experts that their their life is
consenting and working with patients to
know and ensure that it's not coercive
okay thanks looks like we have one more
question for now for precision medicine
and juvenile psychosis what major
changes do you see on the horizon oh so
this is a great question on I think the
biggest change is that the ease of
making stem cells and or organized and
CRISPR are going to change a lot of
trial and error from trying different
medications in a patient to perhaps
trying them in a dish first to see how
the if there is a phenotypic response so
hopefully you know being able to test
things for toxicity for a response on
both in a dish from the patient's own
cells or on the patient's mutation for
trying them in the patient the other
thing is just exome and genome with the
price coming down so much all of a
sudden it's not going to be that unique
I think in the very near future for a
patient's to come in and with a thumb
drive and be like here's my exome or
here's my genome take a look what do you
think and being able to have this type
of even just pharmacology making sure
that you're not going to have a bad
reaction to a drug
at in the medical record to make the
right medication at the right time
verses of this trial and error that we
have to go through right now wonderful I
would like to once again thank dr.
Brownstein for her presentation I would
also like to thank libraries for making
today's educational webcast possible and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August of
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye